I just had a young guy in my office a
lot of times people randomly email me
and say you know I love your passion I
want to know what I'm gonna do in my
life can I see you and you know even
though I have no time those are usually
the ones I take you know I always feel
like that's gonna be the person I might
need in the future too so I'm not just
mother Teresa but you know real great
guy Greg Mueller young kid and he was
talking about what he's doing and wine
and green movement tech and he's going
out to San Fran but something struck me
during our conversation he said uh you
know this is this thing that I've got
it's my identity you know I don't want I
was like you know you need to blog and
you need to tell people who you are and
he said it's my identity and other
people have been saying that too and
just a real big follow up to
distractions yesterday you know you're
not I'm gonna explode
nobody can define who you are guys I
mean the you know the game has changed
you know we talk about all these
products don't be scared to be
multi-dimensional you're not unfocused
you know nobody in this world should
define who you are you can be so many
things I don't want to be just the wine
guy I know a crapload about wine but I
don't want me just a wine guy I remember
what I did Joe Torre rant video how many
people left a comment saying Gary stick
to wine a lot of people always say stick
the wine stick to what you know stick to
science six stick to cooking why don't
we always want other people to stick to
I don't wanna stick to crap you don't
wanna stick to I want to stick to what
makes me happy and what I want to
execute again you know that's what I
want to do I want to execute against my
day and I always talk about that I am
NOT going to allow anybody in this world
not the media not my friends not my
detractors nobody define who I am I'm
gonna define who I am for myself and of
course care about everybody else I mean
anybody who knows me knows that you know
whenever I get zing that I always email
that person I care about what everybody
thinks but ultimately not as much as I
care about executing against my wants
and my needs professionally so please if
you do anything of the Gary Vaynerchuk
videos I've ever put out never ever
allow somebody to define who you are
never be half pregnant half pregnant is
dangerous go in all the way half
pregnant you know kind of in kind of out
go all the way in everything you want
don't worry if you're known as the
mechanic and you want to listen to opera
good for you my man good for you and
don't worry if you're you know a green
kind of chill kid and you've got a
little entrepreneurial spirit in it go
kill it you don't have to ever again
especially with all the tools that allow
us to send our message out there ever
again be pigeonholed execute against you